якщо ми говоримо про воєнний бюджет то
давайте дійсно зробимо видатки які
потрібні на оборону але не будемо ховати
всередину збільшення зарплатні для
посадовців тому що те що ми сьогодні
робимо насправді ну ще буквально мине
пару місяців і нам взагалі не буде чим
платити зарплати і ви знаєте чудово Чому
ви знаєте ситуацію яка склалася в
Сполучених Штатах Америки як одного із
наших на сьогоднішній день будемо
називати своїми іменами головних донорів
і ви знаєте що від нас вимагають
проведення реформ ми засідаємо у
Верховній Раді чотири дні на місяць
Давайте вернемося до нормального графіку
роботи Верховної Ради і займемося
реформами тому що те що ми ділимо
невдовзі може опинитися шкурою невбитого
ведмедя тому що буде просто нема чого
ділити нема чого роздавати